and so I will have to game three is uh
starting here Magnus with the white
pieces a draw or win he will be the
winner of the first match it must win
for Arjun wow and uh Kai I'm very
excited it's my childhood opening the C3
Sicilian probably my favorite opening in
the whole of Chess uh at least when I
was younger and Magnus he's playing it
I've never actually seen him play it
before in a kind of crunch game in a
serious game like this I've played it
against Magnus I've had this position
against Magnus but when I've had white
he's had black and uh yeah it's got a
good decent uh it's got a decent
reputation in the opening and uh pretty
safe for weight if you don't do anything
too crazy what do you think Ivanka I I
think it's an inspired choice I mean
it's something that Eric icy perhaps
wouldn't have expected as you mentioned
and also he's got a lot of experience
playing the black side against you and
did you School him in any variations he
scored me in the opening but I managed
to make a draw when I had white 2009
London chess classic
uh Magnus okay he's brought the White
Knight out via the edge of the board
that's a good tip for everyone at home
you can put your knight on the edge of
the board it's sometimes fine but you've
got to really centralize it very quickly
and he's done that Magnus I didn't go
for this maneuver against him I went for
a different setup for white now White's
Knight jumps in this is still relatively
known stuff and I've seen various games
in this position trendy and uh Arjun
yeah you're right he would never have
guessed this Magnus it seems to be his
idea in all the openings just to
surprise his young rival and it's been
working so far yes throw an Arjun off
balance spending more time on the clock
than we're used to getting a bit of
nerves maybe and uh yeah good choice by
Magnus and he's gonna need some support
energy Arjun error guys see a lot of
Magnus fans of course in the good night
pub in Oslo if you are origin fan if you
want him to strike back which I know
there are a lot of people out there in
the world once then send him some love
on social media use the hashtag chess
Champs uh I want him to strike back I
want another game today I don't want it
to end after three I want a fourth game
and uh yeah there's so many fans out
there and Randy so he does I have to say
Kai he does have a lot of support a lot
of people are cheering for their boy
Arjun and uh he's given her his best you
know yes the results haven't gone his
way so far but you can see he has really
tried only in that game from just now
that was just insane it was absolutely
unbelievable I I have I'm still like
gobsmacked actually fantastic thing
about that game you know how Wild it got
and I do think even though it didn't
quite go arjun's way he needs to do a
little bit more of that
yeah he needs to do a bit more of that
in general I think he maximizes his
percentages he maximizes his odds uh
Arjun if he does make things crazy that
last game that last chaotic tactical
melee he did work out in magnus's favor
but it doesn't always go that way it was
very tiny margins there
um it could easily have ended up in uh
arjun's favor so yeah the thing is what
we're seeing right now Knight's getting
traded Queens potentially coming off
that is magnus's home turf that's his
comfort zone yeah and now that the
Queens are going to get traded off I
mean what chances do you give black to
grind out or win against the world
champion in his element
it's gonna be hot it's not going to be
easy for auction I quite like his last
move the queens were probably going to
get traded off anyway so at least he's
saying yes Magnus we can take the Queens
off the board but it's going to happen
on my terms if white goes and takes the
black queen then Black's Queen side
pawns which are separated right now
they're both isolated they will connect
and uh
at least you improve your structure
somewhat yeah it's going to be hard
though it is going to be hard but two
games in my database one from 2010
finished in a draw between uh mushta
clean over and Carolina Lucan to a
strong woman Grand Masters maybe
International Masters in fact and uh
also a victory for black in the game
between Nisha mahota and asean ochoef so
uh it's possible
it's undefeated in this position it
looks like and uh Magnus is thinking how
can you get the Queens off how does he
guide the game to safety Arjun is going
to put up a fight he's still got plenty
of pieces to do so um well remember if
Magnus wins this game he's not only
going to win the match he will be uh
rated at 2900 in the tour and actually I
have some massive numbers so of course
he lost two huns Niemann on purpose in
the preliminaries if he hadn't lost that
game his um rating right now would
already be above 20 he would be at
29.05. and more impressively his
performance rating in this tournament
would have been three thousand
three thousand is that even possible
apparently I mean it's never been
possible for most Mortals but Magnus uh
he's an exception right and I mean
that's another level yeah have we ever
seen that it's not I think in such a
large sample size with so many games
he's played remember 15 games in the
prelims how many games in The Knockout
so far yeah I mean he's played over 20
games in this tournament 3000 has been
reached before Magnus has got there
before I think in one tournament in
China in 2009 but that was fewer games
that was just nine games
another level we're seeing right now
from the world number one wow wow but
that would only have been if he hadn't
lost I think he lost 15 rating points
losing two hunts
um but definitely if he wins this game
uh probably tomorrow he uh I can't
actually hit a performance rating of 3
000 and winning this game he will reach
2900. the tour ratings and if he draws
this game is he kind of he's close he's
close he can then he can do it tomorrow
uh well that's a critical moment for
Magnus Carl so will he trade of Queens
will he try to force black to trade off
Queens themselves so we'll see what
happens there but uh whilst the players
are thinking well I'm furious you guys
are just amazing sending us some selfies
and we have a selfie from jet licks Arts
who says go go super Magnus and sends us
greetings from the Philippines
evenscape that's the Melt water sign
right that's yeah yeah
very good
and there we do see a trade of queens
and the White Knight steps forward and
we have another selfie from Martin
Rossini who says the Kings battling for
their reign white Sunny Buenos Aires
witness its War and then he asked this
question when do you have the Battle of
the Sexes between Kaya slash Ivanka
against Simon David well it's going to
be you
but hang on a second they didn't
actually say chess yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
I think that's the only one but I I'm
very uncoordinate are you sure you want
me on your team yeah okay yeah yeah
we'll do that here okay yeah well here
we have the picture
and uh there we see Magnus
you just uh
returning to his seat yeah it looks like
he's just changed position there
normally when I change position in my
seat it means that Something's Happened
I've either got very excited about my
position or I'm a bit frustrated and I
want to uh maybe get some energy but
okay Magnus heat remember took the
Queens off the board that is step one
towards just neutralizing any risk
um just maybe guiding the game towards a
draw but you can't play too passive and
we've seen that happen before even
Magnus himself has occasionally been
guilty of that if you play too hard for
the draw it can rebound you can make
passive decisions he's brought his
Bishop out and it feels a bit loose for
white the White's night in the center is
nice but some pressure there the darts
go ahead Bishops
uh it looks like a pin somehow I like
what Audrey's doing I I like what
Arden's doing as well you know he's got
very nice Pawn structure and uh he has
good pieces and like you said there is a
lot of tension in the standoff between
the dark squared Bishops
I was
I was thinking about when you said about
Magnus taking negative decisions I
suddenly had memories of his game
against his match against Duda yeah yeah
he had it in the bag he just needed I
think half a point more that's true and
uh he just kept taking these passive
decisions and he turned a winning
position into a promising position and
then we could see the trajectory go down
and down and until he finally lost it
and the bar is going up for Arjun now
yeah and Michael shook his head yeah
yeah you're right Kai I was about to
point out and Magnus definitely didn't
look happy he's going back to covering
his mouth poker face that kind of
defended defensive body language and
he's got a defend on the board for a few
moves I really like what hydron did with
the black Rook that was unexpected it's
red Magnus shaking his head again and
quite significantly but yeah it's rare
to see a black Rook defend or kind of
develop itself sorry uh kind of this way
up the board normally see the black
Rooks or outside Rooks come across
normally you don't see them Step Up
develop on their starting file
and white has been forced to retreat and
even if we see a trade of dark Square
Bishops that doesn't necessarily mean
the game is
being guided towards the draw it feels
like white is losing a lot of time it's
very tempting as well for black to push
a pole in the middle of the board right
now
starts uh yeah start gaining space
gaining momentum gaining Tempe yeah
what do you think I I agree with you we
do see a trade of dark Square bishop and
a pawn has stepped up the board
um this wasn't the pawn I was expecting
I'll be honest with you I mean I did of
course expect that porn to her to move
forward on one occasion but uh not
immediately yeah maybe you could push
this Pawn to hit the Knight or this Pawn
to hit the Knight I'm not sure which one
um I guess arjun's idea is to keep that
up his sleeve for later this bishop has
been Unleashed and yeah Pawn structure
wise it's definitely better for black
right now black has an extra Central
Pawn it's four versus three on the right
half of the board and on the other flank
I don't know this looks very active to
me this Rook it's keeping up an eye on
this Pawn causes some pressure here um
later if the white bishop ever
disappears The Black Rook can kind of
switch to attack this one okay Magnus
keeps his uh King very safe guiding some
pawns there I just think the king
position as well better for black
Black's King is in the center it's an
end game it's ready to put that kind of
join uh and dart to either side of the
board later Magnus meanwhile his King is
poorly placed but he had to put it here
just to get his Rooks in the game
yeah just I mean if I were Arjun just
automatic just push this Knight back
kick it away force it to retreat
um okay he does that in a different
manner he pushes his Rook to hit the
Knight also looks good also looks good I
think he's trying to provoke Magnus into
protecting his Knight with a pawn
thereby lengthening the diagonal for his
Bishop
sometimes you think it's hitting thin
air but actually it controls a lot of
very important squares there's enough
pieces to cause the white king some
discomfort so instead Magnus steps back
but it's all a bit timid for white
Magnus he's been on fire winning all
these games by kind of playing actively
now he's just trying to draw the world
champion
and Arjun needs to take this opportunity
it's not a big big opportunity but it
feels like a small
glimmer of hope yeah he brings his
remaining piece into the game that black
Rook was doing nothing
yeah just Magnus he needs to somehow
trade off a set of Rooks trade off all
the Rooks if you can if he Trace off all
the Rooks should be a draw
but right now if you compare those
pieces it's clear that blacks are more
active than whites it's not easy to
trade all the Rooks I have to say
because uh The Rook standing there on
the A-line actually has a Target so
black can start bullying white with this
Factor yeah and I really like your plan
of just taking the space on the right
side for me it's like just do it do it I
just push the pawns grab as much space
as possible and uh come on put Magnus
under some pressure yeah I think Magnus
is done to feel the pressure he just
wants to get today done but that's not
normally a good mentality okay he just
pushes pushes upon
again very solid this Pawn is no longer
vulnerable now but this structure we see
from White on the left half of the board
that three
uh White's opponents there there's a
hole in front of them they're
potentially vulnerable to Knights
jumping in later
yeah I don't like it it feels a bit yeah
it's not ideal for white
and again black has a free role to push
on the fight he's stronger he's stronger
with the four versus three majority on
the right half so that's where he should
be playing yeah now I I have uh
nightmares about that pawn structure not
because of any personal games of mine or
anything it's to do with when I was a
child learning I found it very difficult
to read books so my father would read
books with us and he would buy all these
old Soviet books and would sit there
together as a family and he would say
this is the triangle it's terrible it's
terrible and he says look at them they
cut they can easily be restrained and I
just remember that so vividly and I
remember also that one of his things was
that he would set up a position and then
he would kind of take all the pieces
away and we'd have to recreate that
position and that triangle was one of
those exercises
interesting yeah I mean this Pawn
structure for white is just never really
going to move on the left otherwise you
just weaken yourself and meanwhile Arjun
I quite liked his Bishop where it stood
but he's trying to play concretely he's
going for
potential threats direct threats I'm not
sure what it is right now but there is a
pin Black's Bishop is eyeing up this
kind of White Knight that's hanging in
the air
it's very complicated uh in terms of
what to do for white I don't really see
a plan White's Bishop steps back okay
that's looks passive it looks like a
move Magnus didn't want to play but it
does keep the bishop nice and safe that
Bishop was loose vulnerable and anytime
you get pinned you want to keep your
pieces protected
so Arjun how does he increase the
pressure he's the one creating right now
on on the front foot yeah Magnus just
reacting he is reacting I wonder whether
Magnus has any sneaky ideas of uh
potentially trapping the Black Brook or
just asking a question to it yeah maybe
we can show this uh for example I've
been itching for a while to start
pushing these pawns so black pushes one
of them right now
ideas to trap this one maybe pushing a
pawn yeah um so we were talking about
how this is weak this structure or it
can be controlled later by black pushing
a pawn but maybe you take the
opportunity to step forward and
if I'm naive here and just maybe push
the spawn forward and maybe it's not
lost yet but this Rook is yeah in big
big trouble
on the edge of the board also I have a
inkling Magnus has ideas to jump his
Knight in and suddenly there are threats
of the night coming forward with a check
and a fork
Suddenly at least some activity yeah
which didn't exist two moves ago no I
love that night move so you do have to
take precautions there yeah so how are
you going to stop the oh so he Retreats
his Bishop but that's not good I I guess
for Arjun I mean it takes a lot of uh
kind of well you have to get rid of all
your pride essentially all your ego in
order to move your Bishop forward one
square white steps back and then move
your Bishop back
Magnus does indeed jump into the center
so black has actually lost two moves hmm
yeah he's lost two Tempe moving his
Bishop back and forth again
now how does he react
you kind of want to get this rook in the
game but right now there is a threat to
play Rook takes rook and then win a pawn
so he moves his Rook into the center it
feels like Magnus is somehow untangled
she surviving it just feels like yeah
Arjun trying to hurry on the clock as
well but he's lost some time on the
board yeah yeah and I imagine the White
Knight will just relocate itself to the
C4 Square
and actually threaten the pawn on B6 yep
that looks like a very safe move worst
comes to worse you step back into the
center nice Square actually yeah you're
right Ivanka this is uh severe weakness
yeah it's turning it's turning Magnus is
the king of end games after all
Archer needs to be careful
yeah that's uh so easy to lose time like
that and Magnus again making it look so
easy you know he had a slightly
unpleasant position and he seems to have
neutralized that with some
ugly looking moves
and uh Arjun thinking Magnus also
thinking what would he play
yeah it's uh it's tough I mean your move
looks so natural Ivanka just for
treating the White Knight back attacking
the spawn what else I guess you could
trade off a set of Rooks potentially
the reason you might not want to do this
is that black has the option to change
the pawn structure I'm not sure again
whether black actually really wants to
do this but black could unite these
three pawns potentially this one will
push forward later
um so maybe Magnus just weighing up that
option all the top players they always
pause before they change the pawn
structure that's just a pattern because
changing Pawn structures committal long
term and you've got to weigh up long
term whether it's worth it maybe Magnus
I mean this looks too flashy bringing
the bishop out to hit the Rook
I suspect that is going to be the move
yeah I can see that being a Magnus type
of movement yours is more natural and uh
yeah just whoops my arrows are a bit off
today he's attacking this pawn and black
therefore defends it
and yeah I mean for example at the very
least Magnus will drop his Knight back
and just try to trade off this Rook
still in the balance
this game
all right well that's good news for
Magnus a draw is enough for him to
finish this first match in only three
games and now the triangle is on the
store not Unleashed it's uh not there
anymore it's not there anymore and so I
think Magnus was probably quite relieved
to change the pawn structure and now you
can see he's advancing his pawn and it
actually has been has it can become
something that Arjun has to worry about
because it is a potential past Pawn
and uh well Rooks have left the board
the bishop centralizes itself
I I'm like I'm thinking that there's
going to be a turn and that this white
who stands maybe that slightly bit
better yeah look how Magnus he loves to
do this in Middle games end games these
days just pushes all his Rook spawns
forward that means the A and H pawns
just pushes them gain space it's the end
game so you often see Pawn races later
on one side pushing on one flank with
the other side pushing on the other side
and Magnus always seems to be winning
the races because he just plants his
pawns as far up the board as possible
now you know I was about to say he's
going to make an uh an entry path for
the white king towards the center the
white king needs to centralize for later
it feels like he's just going to keep
the status quo forever just going to sit
it's hard to see what black actually
does flax Rook is terribly placed now
Black's Knight is tied down defending
upon Black's Bishop is kind of stuck
plugging the Central File
yeah yeah it just looks like he can sit
do you think uh Magnus even had to think
about these last two moves it was just
with the hand yeah it's like blindfold
chest for Magnus it's just like okay I
want to bring my king to the center I
want to improve a pawn structure piece
that stuff you don't even need to
calculate right he's so good at that and
just uh looking at the camera he looks
like he's in Zen mode
meanwhile poor Arjun he looks like oh no
that's the toughest toughest game in
chess if it's incredibly difficult and I
think one of the great things about Ira
geissing is that he's so cool and he's
so composed and that will just serve him
or just benefit him no end yeah he needs
that youthful optimism now uh just I'm a
bit older and I'm a bit jaded I'm like
oh if I had black in this position okay
draw let's go to tomorrow but Arjun he's
young he's still capable he's still full
of tricks he's got to believe that he
can do it but you know what Simon in the
bar would say
they need to resign you can offer a draw
yeah and it'll be the same thing resign
we do miss our Ginger GM
I think he's having a great time I think
he's not missing us again
that's his favorite place in the world
in the bar playing chess at the same
time lucky people down there they get to
challenge a grand master who is just a
perfect
buncher Blitz player and a pop I bet
they are enjoying themselves also
watching this the other two games were
very explosive very entertaining drama
all the time this one feels a little
calmer yeah and this is magnus's Choice
when you have white part earlier we're
talking about percentages white normally
scores 50 54 on average across all
levels of Chess but the beauty of having
White is you can choose the opening and
you can choose the pace the style of the
opening and here Magnus Guide to the
opening quickly towards the end game
took all the sting out took all the fun
out and although black was probably
doing quite well for a small phase
Magnus is great at killing the Droid
killing or killing the game if he needs
yeah that's yeah bringing his Rook
across we're seeing it right now you
know it looks like a very harmless move
but instead he has intentions of perhaps
pushing his B Pawn and if he pushes the
beep on the a pawn will follow
and it will be eragisi who perhaps might
be more of link for the draw
yeah and clock times nothing serious to
write home about there there we go see
slightly behind
it's just unable to find a plan the
black Rook still what is it doing yeah
much
yeah and whilst uh Arjun is thinking
well Peter saddington sent us a selfie
said let's go Magnus cheering from
Atlanta aha
um we'll bring up the picture
oh wow that is one impressive setup wow
is that the garage it must be looks like
a proper man cave that one yeah doing
some handy work at the same time yeah
it's incredible nice selfie from Peter
and uh well
we have seen the night Retreat and uh
nerdy geographer asks us a question is
there something that you really like I'm
really passionate about but absolutely
suck at and he says that's chess for him
oh that's a good question
uh I know I know what I'm really I'm I'm
really passionate about it I really like
it but a terrible at it it's like
it's like house plants I love them so
much and I want to have a house full of
them but they don't die and uh I get
given these beautiful orchids and it's
like two weeks later I I swear I'm like
watering I'm feeding it I'm doing I'm
reading up on the Internet what to do
and I've killed the thing yeah I think
many people struggle with that for me
it's chess
that sucks but uh we're gonna go down to
um Simon I think the word has spreading
also but you are down there and that
there is a cool watch party at the good
night Simon
there is I mean look at this I think
everyone here is for the watch party
um they're waiting oh actually hanging
mate they're going the wrong way I
Magnus Carlson I'm not we're not yeah
okay well I think we got the wrong cue
there let's go inside let's let's go
inside and here we are we're here at the
good night and uh there's lots of Chess
going on and uh lots of people enjoying
their game enjoying the thing it looks
like Magnus is rolling today he's
playing such good chess and loads of
people are watching the games let's see
a bit more opinion hi guys are you
Magnus Carlson fans yes or no
well yes yes of course is anyone not a
Magnus Carlson fan
oh there we go there's loads there's
loads of fans here and I think
everyone's getting a bit more drunk look
here we go hello
I tell you what yeah we'll talk about
that later are you having a good night
yeah of course there you go everyone's
having a good night here it's getting a
little bit Rowdy you know I'm trying to
hold it together uh I'm trying to watch
the chess uh I mean just look at this
crowd out here I'm sure they're for
Magnus I'm sure they're for Magnus
yeah there we go anyway back to the
studio and um it looks like it's going
to be magnus's day today
it certainly does uh Simon enjoy
yourself it could be an early night for
many people if Magnus gets to join this
game the bar it says 0.0 is a draw
definitely the most likely
I I wouldn't say definitely but it is
the most likely right now it's just hard
to find a plan for either side and
Magnus is just waiting with the white
Rook uh just hinting that he'll push
some pawns Black's King going back
where's that going not entirely clear
um yeah it's just it's completely
balanced that doesn't mean it's going to
be a draw at some point I realize he has
to go for it he might as well but that
will come with some risk entailed as
well and if I could see any chance at
all for black
it's done to lose hope I
primarily it's because it's not very
easy for black to start advancing those
pawns on the right
I mean if you could get a passport
somewhere or just take some space or
just do something positive then I would
feel a lot more optimistic as it stands
I'm just thinking it's Magnus who is
controlling the pace of the game and
there you go he steps forward with a B
Pawn
and it's going to be all about those
pawns on the left yeah I mean this is a
very decisive move it shows that Magnus
is not lacking for confidence uh can't
blame him he's playing so well this
tournament I would have personally is
why it's maybe just started moving the
king towards the center maybe just
pushed white h14 just to clamp down just
to sit there but Magnus he wants to go
for that draw
um at least maybe he wants more
um Eric I see now just Clinging On big
black king the black Rook they're
passively defending Pawns
Yeah the more I look at it the more I
think it's black now on the defensive
and the evaluation bus only creeping up
in White's favor and regardless he had
such a good position but when that's the
problem in chess when you don't or when
you can't find a good plan when you kind
of just move pieces around just for the
sake of it things start to turn and if
you're playing move by move just trying
to react to your opponent then yeah that
will backfire
yeah I mean I can't blame him it's just
a difficult position especially in a
must-win situation he's trying but
what next if white just moves to King
for example if white just Waits I can
move the knights why can
the king uh yeah when he suggested the
king move early instead of the pawn push
I was like of course
that is the way to play and you still
take me by surprise even though I know
that this is what this is the way you
play yeah and I forget but that's why
I'm not Magnus Carson he's a bit more
direct and uh that can be a good thing
too no I I love it David never change
and uh yeah Magnus okay he's caught up
on the clock that's one good sign for
Eric I see maybe one practical uh idea
just would for everybody would be to
wait until both players are down to
about three four minutes or maybe even
less and then start to kind of gamble a
bit take some risks
okay Magnus though he's trying to
clarify things immediately it's trying
too hard to force the draw he's just
taking off a set of Pawns traded off the
Rooks jumping in with his Knight
attacking a pawn but now white pawns
there's a potential for them to be a bit
weak white pawns on the left side are
both isolated
and now uh Arden has the triangle Magnus
uh taking advantage of the hole Yeah
that's just very true but that night is
out there on a limb and it doesn't have
too many squares if the the e-pawn takes
one step forward yeah there's a chance
that white knight might just be on a bad
circuit I guess there's an immediate
threat in the position we talked about
the triangle structure that's this one
that means there's always a hole the
White Knight is doing a good job
occupying and if black is careless and
for example let's say just waste them if
just moves the bishop then white has
this big threat of dropping back with
the Knight hitting this Pawn as soon as
it moves you can jump in with a check
and you win a pawn either way or you can
even go to the edge of the board and win
a pawn like this hit the base of the
pawn chain this is always the way to win
pawns hit the base and uh once the
foundations crack the other pawns drop
as well one of these two will fall it's
a big threat unless Ivanka says maybe
Black's best bet sorry in this position
is to push this Pawn forward it was weak
cultural elaboration
why not step forward I'm thinking maybe
his idea is actually to also challenge
that pawn but you know I'm a pawn Pusher
and maybe I'm like reacting away to uh
to harsh in this I mean it makes sense
you like if you can trade off a bunch of
Pawns you should be able to guide the
game towards the drawer just ignores the
threat wow brings this bishop no but
this is what Magnus wants you know he he
would love to trade I know he pushes the
board maybe he might just wants to win
maybe we're just getting it wrong yeah
I'm gonna um
just reel my words back in commentate
with curse I mean if Magnus wanted to
force the draw there he could easily
have just retreated his Knight and same
idea right if that's what I thought I
thought okay he does that and then it's
gonna be a draw all the pawns are on the
same side but Magnus says no maybe he
played that move very very quickly yeah
and uh Knights are well known to be
really bad at stopping these response
the a h pawns uh this one is about to
start marching through and the bishop
steps back hitting the White Knight and
yeah Magnus he's playing for the world
he's going for he's going for it yeah
and now after this bishop move he can go
to the side of the board right yeah
Magnus is winning you win a pawn whoa
can't defend either this Pawn or this
Pawn
one of them's dropping yeah Magnus has
his sights on 2900 because this is once
again such an incredible performance
yeah
from nowhere he magic that
yeah this is why he's another level he
can change gears he can shift you can
change the pace of the game and every
guy see okay one move he's uh played and
it's all Fallen apart but he was in an
impossible situation anyway it was hard
to win for black maybe even impossible
to win so uh he's going to go down with
his ship and he's going to lose a third
game oh no you just can't save these
pawns if Black's Knight for example
tries to counter-attack against the
Whiteboard and the white porn can
happily step forward and it's still
tough to round this one up the white
Bishop's actually doing a great
defensive job protecting it and uh okay
this happens
which one do you let go maybe you just
let this one drop black king moving but
white is a pawn up
white tonight is just going to come back
and start cleaning up
mopping up the rest of flex Pawns
and the white king you know I hadn't
really moved after a castle suddenly in
Prime position to start moving towards
the right
yeah it looks like it's
um well I was gonna say a matter of
Technique we criticized that phrase the
other day but it looks relatively
straightforward now for white
um I would just get this note back to a
safe Square it doesn't have too many uh
look at Arjun poor guy
um he's just come up against an inspired
opponent today just drop the Knight back
attack this Pawn when it steps forward
now you can start bringing the king
maybe or now you can just centralize
your knight
this Pawn will act as a distraction it
will take black three or four moves to
go and win it in the meantime white will
achieve something else on the other
flank
almost game over now last stages of this
game yeah I have
a suspicion also White's night is going
to do some damage work like you
highlighted go after pawns and oh
the devastation on arjun's face
oh it's hard painful isn't it that's the
thing sometimes against these real elite
players who can step up
I mean I've just been great so far but
he just hasn't had a chance today yeah
sometimes against them you just have to
learn and he does have another
opportunity tomorrow oh he looks he
looks tortured right now we're all
suffering chassis hard game yeah he
knows of course the world is watching a
big chance to play against the world
champion in a match but it hasn't been
his day and we have to also say Magnus
Carlsen is playing
some of his best chests this season on
the tour yeah incredible he's playing
like a legend and uh poor Arjun you know
my heart really feels for him but you
know he will come back stronger and he
has another matchup tomorrow so don't
lose the faith Arjun and the great thing
though is that he has a fantastic
support network around him
you know family great coaches as well
um yeah Arjun still it's only going to
be half time after uh today yeah yeah
still plenty of opportunity okay here
the white king comes
the white apron drops but we will see
okay
we did it blunder yeah well he kind of
blundered away the win
but uh is he losing no is it going to be
a draw probably
but uh I still win anyway
I think he's realized that once the
white king starts coming towards the
center it still looks winning to me oh
it still looked winning to me but once
the white king starts coming there will
be a way to kick it out of the middle of
the board
it's uh yeah still zero risk and yeah
the wind's gone but the match what
today's one match will be over
white is just going to push his G Pawn
now
arjun's still on the defensive despite
clawing his way back somewhat maybe
Magnus is annoyed that the 2900 rating
might be yeah disappearing we know he
loves those numbers
yeah he seems to be in such good perform
but probably he expects to win and
expects to play very good chess and so
this will annoy him that he let slip up
when yeah
and uh I must say this is this
tournament so far at least it's probably
the best I've seen Magnus play since
2019 just since he was just destroying
everyone I mean he's been on a roll he
won what was it nine games or something
in the prelims and then
straight through here
um so far without any playoffs okay a
trade of Pawns the reason this should be
a draw is because simply both sides are
running out of material we'll see a
bunch more exchanges
both sides likely to create past pawns
at some point black Central Pawn is
already a passport I guess yeah and do
you think the white king will also begin
to mobilize itself and move towards the
center most likely yeah
and uh yeah what Magnus Carson
miscalculated is that simply the white
King was too slow to run into the center
black could grab his Pawn uh that white
a pawn earlier and
as you mentioned still should be safe
enough two options here I guess you just
move the white king or you start pushing
the white G Pawn forward
should also be enough to guarantee the
draw yeah
I I was my my first instinct is to push
always I'm never gonna break the habit
of a lifetime and uh Magnus
Magnus also agrees yeah passports are
there to be pushed and I wonder whether
Arjun can maybe drum up something if he
steps forward with his King and stacks
attacks the pawn that's the only plan
right for black black cast to activate
his King it's offside
bring it towards White's Pawn
even if Magnus loses that pawn and we
worse comes to worse for either player
here if you imagine all the pawns
disappearing even if one side loses a
knight or Bishop as long as they only
drop one piece with no pawns left it's
still a draw because now this I can make
a new Queen
and for example a knight and Bishop
against the opponent's bishop or Knight
and Bishop against the opponent's Knight
is still
technically a draw so right now if Arjun
wants to play it safe he can just remove
this white Pawn from the board
remove the other white pawn and
yeah
but then yeah those winning chances just
uh disappear so I think the only way to
keep the game alive is to actually
Retreat the bishop so that you keep the
past G Pawn under lock and key yeah
black can stop that pawn with his
push-up but okay we're gonna see the end
of today's match over the next few moves
why it's not stepping back
even if black spawns disappear remember
it is a draw but uh
okay he'll just try and keep those if
possible and Magnus doesn't even want to
hang around we're going to see this game
end with King versus King and Magnus
takes the first day of the final he does
I draw in the final game he could have
won it even Magnus but three games it is
over he takes the first match in
dominant fashion this means our generic
icy to Morrow will have to win the match
to take it to